joining us now is Elbridge Colby former
Trump Deputy assistant Secretary of
Defense and Victor Davis Hansen senior
fellow at the Hoover institution great
to see you both tonight Victor now 2016
was a rejection of the globalism and the
Elite's plan for America but
what will 2024 be a rejection of
well 2024 is going to be a rejection of
the Biden Administration and a foreign
policy border crime energy the economy
and what's the common denominator to
this is on foreign policy it's
concession concession concession on Iran
on China on all of our adversaries and
neutrals and then at home it's uh print
money and then call it bionomics a
success so it's been a total failure one
really quick thing uh Laura they all
these leaks about Joe Biden about his
character about uh his corruption and
about uh his debility is all designed
that he does not run again but not
they're not evoking the 25th Amendment
they're not talking about removing him
which they did with Trump because that
would give us Kamala Harris so the
narrative now is he can't run again but
he's got to finish the second that his
first term so that Kamala Fades into the
2024 primary uh for other candidates now
Elbridge speaking of Ukraine as we were
talking about earlier in the angle um I
want to get your thoughts on the bite
Administration shifting feelings on
cluster bombs watch this
there are reports of illegal cluster
bombs and vacuum bombs being used by the
Russians if that were true it would
potentially be a war crime the
administration is going to provide
cluster Munitions to the ukrainians what
made you uh change your mind and decide
to give them these weapons the
ukrainians are running out of ammunition
and we're low on it and so what I
finally did took the recommendation of
the defense department
Albert I'm sure they didn't care for him
actually saying the United States of
America is low on Munitions yeah plus
plus mainstreaming normalizing cluster
bombs now right well I think the the
admission by the president on 155
millimeter rounds which are actually
very standard and relatively simple
weapons that were depleting them is a
huge admission and I'm not sure why
they're taking any kind of Victory lap
because the war in Ukraine unfortunately
looks like it's going to be protracted
unfortunately the counter-offensive
they're not winning the war is that
correct where's the counter offense I
mean they're probing we hope they do
well of course but so far it seems to be
pretty modest now there could be a
breakthrough but it I don't think that's
going to decisively end the war anytime
soon if at all and at the same time
they're going to China and they're
sufficiently provocative to be offensive
to the Chinese who believe they're
trying to strangle them but not doing a
good enough job at it to actually hold
the Chinese back at the same time Iran
is moving to become something close to a
threshold state so why are they taking
Victory I think a lot of it is just the
Optics of going to a NATO Summit it's
basically play this symbolism but
actually we're on a really bad
trajectory as far as I can tell now
Victor to elbridge's point you know John
Kerry who I think has the most power of
anyone in the administration he's not
Senate confirmed he's heading to China
to resume talks with the CCP China's not
sending anyone here we're just going
there hat in hand
um what of that and what does this mean
I mean I've been tweeting about this
saying this is really a slow but sure
Surrender by the United States to the
donor class into Wall Street but your
thoughts on that it
it is we haven't built a coal plant in
over a decade China builds one or two a
week that's he's oblivious to that for
John Kerry it's all about concessions to
our adversaries he did the same thing
with the Iran deal he leveraged that
deal by making us give concessions to
the benefit of Iran he did the same
thing when he was secretary of state
with Russia vis-a-vis their presence in
Syria we got them back into the Middle
East and he's doing the same thing in
China it's always the United States
gives concessions and then John Kerry is
the wizard who cements the deal to our
disadvantage and to the benefit of our
adversaries and I think he's probably
you know one of the most naive Secretary
of States we ever had and now he's
continuing that role as so-called
climates are and it's to our
disadvantage that's very predictable
and Albert you get the sense that when
John Kerry talks about well we have to
get used to this transition there's
going to be Capital deployed and it's
going to be great in this new era of of
green policies you get the sense that a
lot of these people are just setting up
their next thing you know they're
meeting all these Chinese people you get
the sense that this is going to be a you
know a quick off-ramp to the next job
for a lot of these individuals and if
China's has the power why not make the
connection with China I know that's a
cynical thing for me to say but it
certainly looks like it well and I think
their ideology is often more
transnationalist than it is about what's
best for the United States and I think
it's not an accident that the Chinese
invited blinken yelling and rightly as
you said the Optics are terrible and I'm
sure they'll be just as bad uh with John
Kerry and I think that's very disturbing
about what what we're you know offering
to the Chinese which is allowing
ourselves to be played in this way and
of course the Ridiculousness you know
this whole competing while cooperating
or Yellen said healthy competition I
mean this is not a game of tennis that
you know she said she said that this is
not the president doesn't see this is
great power rivalry it's absolutely a
great power rivalry and you can be sure
the Chinese see it that way so even if
we don't admit it that's extremely
disturbing have they seen the trade
deficit it's the largest trade deficit
and Victor you've mentioned this before
it's the largest trade deficit we've had
I think ever consistently month to month
to month with China alone so a healthy
competition it's it's a one-way
competition and China's winning
now they call that cooperation but it's
more of the same we saw in Anchorage
Alaska we saw where the origins of covid
they were silent about we saw it with
the balloon Fiasco we see it with
buzzing our ships and planes in the
South China Sea it's always concession
concession cooperation the Chinese don't
see it that way they see it that they're
winning and LG's is right they see it as
a rivalry in which they have all the
cards of Advantage uh Elbridge Victor
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else